in Berlin geht's derweil ganz konkret um
ihr Geld um die Frage wie teuer wird der
Winter jetzt nun wirklich das
Bundeskabinett will heute den Weg für
weitere Entlastung frei machen ja im
Dezember soll es schon losgehen mit der
Übernahme von Abschlagszahlungen und es
gibt weitere gute Neuigkeiten statt dass
die gasbremse erst nächsten März greift
gibt es einen Beschlussentwurf der
besagt das ist schon ein Monat früher im
Februar losgehen könnte sprechen wir
darüber hier in unserem Studio jetzt
Bild politikchef Jan Schäfer schön dass
du jedes Jahr die Zeit drängt viele
schon in ihren Geldbeutel und fragen
sich was ist denn nun und haben vor
allem auch Schwierigkeiten was wie kann
ich überhaupt irgendetwas billiger
bekommen bring ein bisschen Licht ins
Dunkel es ist ja wirklich auch
kompliziert genau heute ist ein großer
Tag was die Beschlüsse angeht muss man
sagen noch nicht die Umsetzung aber die
Beschlüsse genau vollkommen richtig
dieser sogenannte gasabschlag der im
Dezember ansteht für alle Haushalte die
eine Gasheizung haben oder auch eine
Fernwärmeheizung der soll heute
geschlossen werden als beschlossen
worden vom Kabinett muss jetzt einmal
noch durch den Bundestag das dauert
immer noch ein paar Tage aber dann haben
Millionen Mieter und auch Eigentümer die
Hoffnung dass sie wenn ich im Dezember
aber so zumindest im Frühjahr oder
vielleicht auch erst im Sommer mit der
Nebenkostenabrechnung dann für einen
Monat den gasabschlag erstattet bekommen
und zwar vom Steuerzahler vom Staat und
dann gibt es heute den großen
bund-ländergipfel am Nachmittag ab 15
Uhr und dort geht es um weitere
Entlastungen unter anderem um du hast es
gerade schon gesagt die gaspreisbremse
und die strompreisbremse beide soll im
nächsten Jahr kommen die
strompreisbremse soll eingeführt werden
zum ersten Januar das bedeutet dass der
Strompreis dann gedeckelt wird bei 40
Cent pro Kilowattstunde ist
ehrlicherweise muss man sagen ziemlich
hoch wir liegen jetzt etwas über 40 Cent
aber wir lagen bisher deutlich deutlich
drunter und deswegen aber immerhin eine
Deckelung ist dann da 40 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde aber nur für einen Teil
des Verbrauchers nämlich für 80%
und dann gibt es die gaspreisbremse auf
die sich ja auch schon viele viele
Menschen freuen die bisher im März
kommen sollte sie soll jetzt im Februar
kommen das soll heute Nachmittag
beschlossen werden und ebenfalls wird
hier der Gaspreis gedeckelt bei ungefähr
12 Cent pro Kilowattstunde und das
passiert nun wie gesagt nicht im März
sondern mutmaß ich schon ab Februar
Achtung wieder ein Haken da die
Umsetzung schwer ist wird man das wohl
rückwirkend machen zum ersten Februar
bedeutet sie greift erst im März keine
Sorge aber man bekommt den Februar dann
auch schon
rückerstattet mit dieser gaspreisbremse
die auch und das gehört noch dazu um es
vollständig zu machen nur für 80% des
gesamtverbrauches gibt also die
Haushalte bezahlen 4/5 dessen was im
verbrauchen mit dieser Preisbremse und
das letzte Fünftel was sie verbrauchen
das wird dann zu normalen Marktpreisen
damit sehr teuer bezahlt du sagst es
gerade die gasnutzer freuen sich die
gaspreisbremse kommt aber ist das
wirklich eine ger die Regelung also ich
meine was ist mit denjenigen die mit Öl
heizen das ist richtig das es gibt auch
viele Beschwerden ungefähr jeder vierte
Haushalt in Deutschland heizt noch mit
Öl gerade auf dem Land ist die Ölheizung
noch sehr verbreitet dass es eine
dauerkritikpunkt auch an dem was die
Ministerpräsidenten heute mit der
Bundesregierung beschließen es gibt
einen sogenannten
härtefallfonds für jene Haushalte die
mit Öl heizen aber trotzdem am Ende
ihrer finanziellen Kräfte sind die
können sich dann an diesen Vorwänden wie
genau das dann funktioniert das muss
noch ausgestaltet werden aber richtig
ist auch es gibt keine direkten Hilfen
also es gibt keine
ölpreisbremse zumindest nach jetzigen
Stand nicht jetzt können wir aus der
Vergangenheit bei anderen Themen dass
ich Bund und Länder nicht unbedingt
immer sind bei gewissen Themen wo liegen
heute in diesem so wichtigen Tag die
größten Knackpunkte ein großer
Knackpunkt zumindest in den Stunden auch
in der Vorbereitung dieses Gipfels die
letzten Stunden war das 49 euro-ticket
das Nachfolge der Nachfolge Fahrschein
für dieses sagenumwurmel 9 euro-ticket
aus dem Sommer warum gab es da Probleme
weil das Ticket von den Ländern extrem
gewünscht wird ist verständlich aber die
Finanzierung immer ein Problem ist denn
für 49 Euro bundesweit zu fahren
bedeutet natürlich dass irgendwo anders
das Geld herkommen muss es kommt dann
wieder von allen vom Steuerzahler und in
dem Fall ist es sehr aus dem Säckel des
Bundes also der Bundesregierung da hieß
es bisher 1,5 Milliarden sollte der Bund
zusteuern das war den Ländern zu wenig
und jetzt muss man einfach schauen wie
es am Ende ausgeht aber auch da sehen
wir die Signale man wird sich einigen
fraglich ist wann startet das 49 Euro
Ticket es sollte bisher zum ersten
Januar kommen wir sehen aber in den
Vorlagen die es jetzt gibt für den
Gipfel heute das ist heißt so schnell
wirklich könnte also auch erst der
februar werden vielleicht auch 1 März
schauen wir gespannt was da heute am
heutigen Tag alles entschieden wird das
geht nämlich um Ihren Geldbeutel zu
Hause haben wir natürlich ein ganz
genauen Blick drauf Jan Schäfer danke
für dein Besuch
[Musik]